foreign
thank you very much for coming here to
Strasbourg I am simply appalled by the
recent disasters that struck Greece and
its people you have shown me the
pictures it's unspeakable
for the first time we see that your
country faced the most dramatic
wildfires that the U.S ever seen never
ever before such a vast area has been
destroyed by the wildfires then
floods have devastated large regions of
Greece for example The Plains of tessali
the pictures from Larissa are
heartbreaking
and let me assure you that our thoughts
are with all the women men and children
who are courageously withstanding these
disasters and we mourn the lives lost
Europe stands at the side of the Greek
people and I want Greece and the Greek
people to know that we are with them our
Union is a union of solidarity
it was therefore very important for us
to be able to meet here today kariakos
many thanks for coming and to discuss
this solidarity together with your
ministers and our commissioners
we spoke about the best ways how to help
the Greek people a lot of investment
will be necessary to rebuild but right
now also a lot of immediate support and
help is necessary to restore the
livelihoods
my main message is that the commission
will be inventive we will be quick and
we will be flexible
we will mobilize all EU resources that
can be deployed and let me focus on five
important funding streams that could be
mobilized
first we should use unspent cohesion
money from the last period which would
otherwise be lost
so it's fresh money
and front load parts of the current
cohesion funds
second the same goes for the European
social fund plus that could be mobilized
here too
These funds would be lost and can be
dispersed this year
so part of the money that can
immediately go to Greek citizens to
support will also be European money
the third element is the common
agricultural policy that can play an
important role
here are two unused funds from the
previous Greek rule development program
but we also look into funds under the
current Greek cap strategic plan
and we will examine the agricultural
reserve for next year
if we look at those funds they could for
example help restore forest or farming
infrastructure a lot is needed to be
done
all together
this could allow Greece to mobilize up
to
2.25 billion euros
and then in addition
the commission stands ready to assess a
Greek request for support under the
solidarity fund
here it is important that the member
States agree on our proposal to top up
the solidarity fund and if this happens
next year we could make available up to
400 million euros
and finally Greece could consider to use
some of the resources of Next Generation
EU
of course in Next Generation EU we have
all to show utmost flexibility because
the revision was just submitted so we
will work with it
my services will work closely on all
these operation options with the Greek
authorities we have decided to form a
task force that immediate will
immediately will start its work today
together we will find the best possible
ways to help the Greek people
and the Greek people can count on Europe
for fast support maximal flexibility And
We Stand By Your Side not only at in
this acute moment but also to rebuild
and reconstruct
thank you thank you madam president
first of all thank you for the speed
with which you responded to my request
to meet you and your team to discuss as
we have done today in a very
constructive meeting the ways in which
Europe can stand by the people of Greece
during these extremely difficult times I
would first and foremost uh uh address
the gravity of the situation at hand
Greece has over the past month endured
the two devastating natural disasters of
historic proportions uh the mega fire in
the region of Everest is the largest
fire in Europe's history
and if that was not enough then we were
hit by the massive storm Daniel which
hit the regions of thessaly and Central
Greece particularly hard we've had the
worst floods in our history this is
probably one of the most powerful storms
to ever hit Europe
um my I would like to again express my
condolences to those who lost loved ones
during this storm I would like to thank
our emergency response
teams the Civil protection are on Force
as all the volunteers who are still as
we speak active in the field dealing
with the aftershocks of this
unprecedented natural disaster this is
just one photo of the village of
metamorphosis how it was before the
storm how it is now and unfortunately we
have dozens of villagers that are in a
similar situation we've had massive
damage to our agricultural production
significant damage to our infrastructure
but and most profoundly damaged to
people's lives I mean houses have been
flooded so it is our number one priority
to make sure that these people can
actually return to their houses that the
businesses can start operating again and
we count on on your support to be able
to achieve that the good thing is that
at least our economy has been performing
very well we are in a position to cover
many direct needs without deviating from
our budgetary
targets but I think it is
urgent as you said for the European
Union to show maximum support but also
maximum flexibility and to come up with
innovative ideas of how to support
Greece immediately but also in the short
to medium I'm a term and I think you
touched upon many of the areas we've
discussed we still have
additional unused funds which would have
been lost as is you know always the case
in these programs that can be I think
reappropriated to immediately support
people and businesses I think it is
important to know that part of the
support that they will be receiving over
the next weeks will eventually also
include a European money and of course
reprogramming of the financial
instruments that we have for the next
programming period would allow us to
direct more than 2 billion euros towards
reconstruction but also building back
better what has been destroyed and I do
want to stress that because it is very
clear that the current rules of the game
no longer the old rules of the game no
longer apply to what it is we are uh we
are experiencing uh and uh of course
this is also true for the instruments
that Europe needs to mobilize uh to
support countries that suffer the
consequences of climate change now we've
discussed numerous times and the
commission is very supportive towards
the idea of committing significantly
more funds to the solidarity fund the
solidarity fund uh was conceived 20
years ago it is clearly not fit for
purpose not in terms of the processes
but in terms of the size of of funds
available so I will make it my personal
mission to convince my colleagues at the
European Council that we need to top up
the solidarity fund would significantly
more available funds in order to support
countries that are struck by natural
disasters directly related to climate
change but also other types of natural
disasters where countries need need
support and of course this is also true
for the agricultural Reserve it's less
than 500 million in these days of a
significant impact of of climate change
it is also very clear that we need to
mobilize additional funds for this
purpose there are many ideas but we need
to convince our colleagues at the
council that this is an utmost uh
priority I think the important thing now
is as you pointed out not to despair we
will uh you know we will build back uh
Europe is going to support us in this in
this effort and I would like to thank
you again Madame President for the speed
with which you have responded to my
request I would like to point out that
we have already set up as you said a
task force that is going to do the
detailed work of overcoming you know the
traditional uh bureaucracy and making
sure that whatever money is dispersed by
Europe reaches its final destination as
uh quickly as possible and I know that
as in many other instances
during the past years we can count on
your personal support we can count on on
Europe support Europe has supported
Greece during very difficult periods and
I'm sure it will do the same now
thank you very much
all right very good